oh hello yes
guys guys so check it out Hitchcock who
fell asleep in the break room so I put
his hand in a bowl warm water
come on man that's the stupidest prank
ever ah no it's the smartest because it
involves biology I bet it worked already
let's go Jack
Hitchcock no he's drowning he's drowning
hey man take it back Jake
great prank hey Charles can we talk in
the briefing room for a second there's a
question I got to ask you it's happening
Jake is gonna pop the question he's
gonna ask me to be his BM no BN best man
it's a common abbreviation no one but
you has ever used it I am so relieved I
thought maybe he was gonna ask one of
Amy's brothers or who Sarge hey there
come on Charles
okay so I know this is a lot to ask so
it's not I want to do it you want to
cover my shift this weekend so I can go
to the White Plains mall and meet Darryl
Strawberry at the opening of a cell
phone store yes it's exactly what I was
hoping you'd ask
great thanks you sure it's okay mmm very
happy about it
that'll be fun I'll be fun look at my
smile I have to go now
change what do you say bud will you be
my PM yes yes a million times yes in
your face Terri what I'm on the sparkler
for your helped organize a lot of this
we can stick that sparkler but I'm the
best man
it's Halloween I'm surprised you didn't
put on the costume I was going to sir
but then I decided screw that jazz well
I'm the only one who ever dresses up no
one ever gets my costume and they make
fun of me so I'm done these people don't
deserve my dress-up gifts
Charles seriously no costume what the
hell Charles where's your Halloween
spirit
but you guys always make fun of me I
have never once insulted you in my life
especially these Ivy your appearance
yeah man we always loved your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and/or thing yes I do remember
sir
permission is sprint to my car and get
my emergency costume does it matter if I
say no no
a bam bam boom why are you dressed up
you look like an idiot
yeah what he supposed to be a sassy car
mechanic no come on he's clearly the
rejected pop-tarts mascot harry pop-tart
I'm not you know Who I am squat that's
enough you're making boil foot bath on
purpose he's Elvis yes Elvis Stojko the
Canadian finger skaters oh I'm so glad
we could finally do this
I know Kylie says you're always stuck
into brazing yeah speaking of this is
work sorry what's that process everybody
back there's a lead on the nightingale
strangler we're looking for a white male
510 medium build brown hair small scar
on his right cheek okay his MO is he
finds lonely women with no friends
poisons their food and then guts him in
his van pretty gnarly last seen wearing
a salmon shirt gray blazer and witnesses
have said he has trouble fitting lettuce
in his mouth okay where are you
apparently has the world's smallest
penis and doesn't know how to use it hi
there
I'm Jake Peralta Amy's boss but that's
not true what are you doing here I am
here on a date who is now leaving worth
it have a great night your boss seems
really nice he's not my boss yes I am
I'm here I'm here I'm here you can start
the meeting now the meeting is over
you're late you missed roll call and the
tutorial on using the new copier six
years and no matter how hard I try I
still can't get you to understand the
importance of being punctual maybe you
should just give up and accept me for
who I am no I will break you right now
while you were out being tardy I was
hard at work devising a special
punishment I've crafted an intricate
personal high-five with everyone in this
office except you what but you hate
high-fives yes every minute of it was
hell but it'll be worse for you
squad dismissed
goodbye Diaz sure bye Jeffords
that's the buck-buck goodbye Santiago
double fist bump reverse explosion into
a bouncing strap all right that was
terrible but it's over now and I made it
through the violator from Xerox the copy
tonight you're not giving us any new
cases there's nothing to work on damn it
so this is how it ends well every ending
is a new beginning another great Gina
linetti entrance you better savor these
while you still can Sarge Audrina I am
not in the mood
how are you so unaffected by all this
because I have already moved on I'm
devoting my energy to my new project
Gina's on it's a one-stop online portal
for my legions of followers
speaking of heel what's up g hive it's
Queen G I'm bored at work so I'm gonna
prank all my coworkers
that sounds like a bad idea for an
already crappy day fine Sarge I won't do
it I will do it so you can count this as
my first prank I guess I'm a fish hey
can I talk to the captain uh he's on the
phone do you want a coffee while you
wait they made me an extra line on
accident Wow
sure thank you oh my god what is that
man you just drank some man guys check
back in to see if she dies well you're
not really gonna die probably okay just
a little honey for the G hive also you
can talk to hold he is not on the phone
what is happening it's a little
something Michael do pranks for the
present one
Santiago I'm on the phone
Sarge I got a case for you guy that's
phone stolen at a bar last night oh it's
not that big a deal I just need to file
a police report for my insurance company
no it is a major injustice and we're
gonna set it right there's a crappy old
phone I'd rather just get a new one but
the wood police and we're here to help
you I only saw his back had a blue
hoodie on you just drank cement you just
drank cement it's over yes I agree
up down separation separation Oh
girl you look so sad you know it would
cheer you up nice bowl of miso soup
no thanks Gina I'm not in the mood so
Gina is that soup up for grabs Scully no
my followers are sick of watching you
eat some mint the precinct will not be
shut down they decided to shut down the
seven-four instead wait I don't
understand
apparently the community came to our aid
there was a swell of online support
orchestrated by an organization called
China's own I think you mean Gina's on I
was behind the bar the whole time
another great Gina linetti entrance I
told you you can't be back here
and I told you already Anna what did you
do I was live-streaming a prank when
captain Holt made his big speech about
how you did the right thing for the city
I guess people were moved they were like
what can we do to help but I said call
the commissioner's office the G hive is
real I can't believe you did it Gina
you're a legend to the nine-nine
yeah Sumi
have a nice weekend Peralta yeah and
that's a special yeah I got a you missed
Scully's birthday he's kind of a big one
nobody showed at the party guys guys
guys we missed Scully's birthday and it
was a big one I know I panicked and said
I had to go to the vet because my puppy
cat got sick I said I had to take my mom
to get birth control pills that's better
than my excuse I said I had to go to our
girls bat mitzvahs squad we missed
Scully's birthday and it was up big one
I told them I was in Ecuador I think
they bought it
we gotta make it up to him let's give
him cash everyone put in $20 each ah yes
I'll cover you it's going oh we're sorry
that we missed your party well I don't
worry about it yeah all that stuff to do
yes the capital of Ecuador is Quito Oh
anyway happy birthday from all of us
thank you you're the best I can't
believe it the fake birthday work you're
a genius
we're both geniuses pumpjack but that
was my thumbtack guys I have a great
idea for a prank before Holt comes in
I'm gonna put ink on the podium where he
puts his hands I don't think you'll fall
for that I did
wow I haven't even opened this yet -
guess it's unrelated you have been holed
hates pranks this is gonna backfire man
yeah fine I'll tone it down I'll move
his podium a foot to the left what he'll
be so angry okay five inches five three
three one one all right
I'll move it a half inch fine it's your
funeral where's prank effort so stupid
Holt's 19 minute notice good morning you
guys that the podium how did you pull
this off
you